next game would be held at Rowan's
Zoological Institute and feature William
Easton in being forced to make the same
kind of life or death decisions about
who will receive Health Care coverage
only now in person regarding his own
employees you know this one's going to
be spicy meanwhile in the background
Erickson and Perez discovered that the
knife used to cut the jigsaw piece from
the latest victim matches the knife used
to cut the jigsaw piece from Seth Baxter
but doesn't match any of the other
victims their suspicion of Hoffman
continues to grow as they learn that
strom's fingerprints were placed after
he was already dead and eventually they
de-scramble the voice on the Seth Baxter
jigsaw tape revealing none other than
detective Mark Hoffman